[Music]
uh Brandon Trump talks about the lowest
point in his life
and for me what I think is that every
morning he wakes up is the lowest point
in his life but that's just me let's see
what he says we're at uh groundworks
coffee
Brian goes meet me for coffee yeah he
trained so hard I was with him the whole
time he trained so [ __ ] hard and
Travis Brown comes in and Brendan just
didn't want to fight and long story
short on top it's just hitting [ __ ]
Brandon they call out that's done and he
goes like this I come over to him as he
gets out of the cage and he goes I try
and I go it's okay it's okay because I
tried I go it's okay and you [ __ ] go
and I see you and I go I'm picking you
up at it's the next day two days later
no it was after yeah it was it was
actually support broken yeah before you
just you're just lowest point of your
life and I remember I took a picture of
you and I have the picture it's
hilarious black guy I have it on my own
I'm in a tank top
I'm gonna take this picture
I'm taking this picture right now
because this is the lowest point of your
life it's very important to documentary
goes lowest point in your life on let me
document oh there stare there and boom
like that and we had it and it was just
like well here's the we're in the valley
sometimes you're at the top of the
mountain other times you got to get to
the valley
good good that's a good analogy you're
smart guys super insightful and who I
forgot which one of you guys said it
before the show but one of you guys
mentioned like oh because you went
through the whole [ __ ] everybody
making accusations to you now you're the
shot yep you're the shaman you're the
shaman of of of the Peaks and valleys
yeah he's reached Enlightenment have you
seriously every man Royce because like I
said it looks like you're running
numbers for Sammy the bull so I mean I
get it but come on
part of one mountain is the the
beginning of the next Mountain's life
when you order fries sometimes it comes
with truffle on it but sometimes it
comes with a lot of truffle on it and
then you can just ask for even more
truffle yeah hey Brian why aren't you in
the Goldbergs anymore
I love that it's true it's anything to
be able to be like is you know this was
a you're gonna have a fall Summit after
this no you know you've seen Rocky right
yeah no no I've never seen it what's the
movie about Brandon
I would give money to have Brendan
describe the plot of Rocky to me
I would love nothing more than Brendan
shop to have to describe it
here's the thing Yuri Papa then he meets
this [ __ ] girl working at a pet shop
B you'll be a Mrs [ __ ] girl and she
wasn't diabetes both dime piece bro
takes her to a zoo yeah yo this thick
boy named Rocky Bal bolognes is really
good Abalone boxing
[Laughter]
and a stream and you want to get to a
Michael Pond or Michael Blake and then
you climb the mountain and then the fall
Summit was just oh I guess there's
another Valley so you're gonna do that
and then you're gonna be on the planes
for a while it's not gonna be the same
straight into the plane for a little bit
and then you go Valley again is there
any other way is there it I'm sorry what
are they saying
they're all saying it at the same time
you're in the same room this shouldn't
like be a problem if you're in the same
way you know it's not even like they
have the zoom thing like you brought up
earlier no I don't understand what are
you guys doing
any other way in life this is like an in
real life Zoom call with no latency but
the same etiquette
he look brand you know what Brian Callan
looks like the way he's dressed the way
he looks the way he's talking he looks
like a guy who was an alcoholic for a
really long time but turned it around
for a year and he's already excitedly
telling people how to do it
oh yeah he's like everyone's sponsor yes
exactly you gotta work it bro you gotta
work the program yeah don't let the
program work you you work it okay don't
work yourself into a shoot either yeah
brother
um no no he looks like he's about to
tell an entire Silicon Valley audience
about his new tech that can record
feelings
this guy's constantly he does look like
he's constantly meeting drunks at two in
the morning for a cup of coffee exactly
they they know him by name at those
local Waffle House yes because he's
always there with them yeah hmm
hey what's up Janine normal just uh
coffee black and some waffles yeah
that'll be fine
so what happened man you were doing so
well yeah man listen it's just listen
man we're just gonna have to turn it
around man tomorrow we start back day
one again Peaks and valleys brother
Peaks and valleys brother Peaks and
valleys
[ __ ] annoying motivational speaker
Brian Cowan
way than to eat dicks most of the time
especially here's when you everybody
here has been in these situations and
thank God everybody everybody here has
been a bit of New York Times article
right everybody right everyone's been
oh you haven't by the way which it was
[ __ ] I still believe that all those
were more [ __ ] liars and regardless
how much you make fun of Brian Callan
that was [ __ ] and everybody knows
that's [ __ ]
say everybody here is eating death
everybody hears me they're all eating
dick and the teacher's like yeah
everyone here is like called the fake
bombing on the lady on a train
everyone's done that oh you haven't oh
no you haven't oh yeah you're perfect a
Mr Perfect oh I never did
oh
my God you just repeated this joke back
to him
he's just he's the best stupid
every one of us here at least has been
in a row boat in the middle of the ocean
with no land in sight no paddle
could it really put you guys in that
situation that sounds great I'll buy the
boat okay and I'll break the battle
that that's the that's the nature of
real chaos where you're like I'm in the
middle of a robot and the only thing
you'll have for sustenance is cans of
rain energy drink
I would have brought you guys some soup
but somebody spilled it on a van Gogh
Bank
for climate change yeah yeah so you
should feel good about yourself
but and I don't know I can't see land
and I don't I don't I don't but the
brain your work the system got me
because it's exactly what they would say
yeah I work the program every day
powdered creamer and old coffee
it's just hanging out at some old
Catholic Church in the parking lots of
cigarettes exactly chain smoking
cigarettes at the parking lot
oh [ __ ] it looks like a scene from
[ __ ] fight club
all right that's enough of him let's
play My Demons Club Papa